philippe couillard on avait fait un
engagement pendant la campagne
électorale il faut 10 et il améliorer la
qualité des transports collectifs dans
l'ouest de l'île de montréal selon lui
ça passait par ce projet de train de
l'ouest mais jean-sébastien cloutier
nous présente en détail ce projet le
trait vert vaudreuil hudson est le
deuxième plus achalandée dans la région
de montréal avec plus de trois millions
et demi de déplacement chaque année mais
ses usagers sont insatisfaits l'équipe a
beaucoup de prêts
car si l'autre reine de twitter et le
passé ou ouvrir 7
ils se sont donc réjouis d'entendre
philippe couillard pendant la campagne
électorale
on va avancer le projet de train de
l'ouest mon intention de le réaliser
priorité du nouveau gouvernement libéral
ce projet est donc remis sur les rails
voilà une vingtaine d'années que les
élus réfléchissent sérieusement à
améliorer ce service ferroviaire
l'objectif le plus récent comprendre et
la construction de deux nouvelles voies
ferrées des gars de la chine à sainte
anne de bellevue le long des voies
actuelles qui appartiennent au canadien
pacific sur ce tracé
plusieurs trains de l'entreprise
circulent chaque jour vous pouvez voir
la côte de l'espace cas a ajouté l'élu
l'ancien ministre
cliff linken et porte-parole de la
coalition qui fait la promotion du
projet évalué autour d'eux milliards de
dollars ça veut dire une denis dédié
additionnel qui ont permettre que les
passagers ne soient pas encombrée par
les trains de marchandises mettant les
trains de marchandises ont priorité
nous on veut que les trains de passagers
puissent circuler librement comme par
exemple le train des deux montagnes
alors une fréquence beaucoup plus accrue
de trains actuellement la ligne qui va
du centre ville vers vaudreuil hudson
offre 26 départs chaque jour de semaine
soit 13 dans chaque direction
avec le nouveau projet l' agence
métropolitaine de transport avancent
qu'il pourrait y avoir jusqu'à 86 départ
43 dans chaque direction
ce matin là tous les usagers rencontrés
espérait les améliorations sont de
pointe soit trouvé de la place où
des fois même les heures de passage s'il
y aurait plus de train fait que ça
changerait les heures de passage que ce
serait plus convié niant le dernier
traite à 16h30 du monde de montréal pour
retourner alors 6 passes et césar le
fonds attend jusqu'à 9h15 comprendre
prochain très bon ici de l'ouest
vraiment une priorité surtout avec les
nouvelles constructions et les
rénovations qui s'en vient je recoupe
sauce avec la rentrée mais à l'heure où
les fonds publics se font rares et où la
mt à elle seule a jusqu'à 17 milliards
de dollars de projets en tête si 2020
pourquoi devrait-on prioriser celui du
train de l'ouest
après tout les lignes de train vers
saint-hilaire candiac au sud ou vers
saint jérôme où nous offre encore moins
de départs que la ligne de l'ouest
d'abord on veut faire de ce projet un
deux pour un ce nouveau train de l'ouest
deviendrait si la navette souhaitait
depuis longtemps entre l'aéroport pierre
elliott trudeau et le centre ville
même si la gare de trains actuels de
dorval est à un kilomètre de l'aéroport
faire dans le même projet d'accès à
l'aéroport je veux pas que deux voix
différentes faut que ce soit la même
le même projet qui unit l'accès à
l'aéroport dorval et le centre ville car
vous allez à paris à charles de gaulle
vous embarquer dans le rer vous
embarquer dans l'erreur de tous les
parisiens et vous arrivez au
centre-ville puis les anglo montréalais
fidèle aux libéraux veulent qu'on les
écoute
soixante personnes le taxer très jours
voir la ville de montréal elle contribue
au métro on contribue métaux contribuer
aux autobus et nous on est toujours
grosjean avant on veut ne pas assez tout
autre argument la population qui est en
hausse à vaudreuil dorion les maisons
poussent déjà comme des champignons
depuis longtemps la population de la
ville a doublé depuis 1995 et plus de la
moitié de ses résidents travaillent dans
l'île de montréal
le maire guy pilon dit oui au nouveau
train de l'ouest mais pas n'importe quel
prix pour sa ville c'est bien beau de se
lancer dans ces projets là qui devront
se faire d'après moi mais les
questionnements que tous les matchs se
pose est quel va être le coût
d'exploitation est ce qu'on va être
capable de me détendre éventuellement au
15 mai au 20 mai le son ne durera pas
mais ils vont transporter combien de
personnes à ce moment-là l'extérieur les
a donc peut-être pour beaucoup mais le
train côte au sial lorsqu'il ya 75
passagers ou cannes et 560 guy pilon
sait de quoi il parle il a siégé au
conseil d'administration de la mt et a
été président de la commission des
transports de la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal
c'est certain que le gros défi qui va y
avoir ça va être de plus aux lésés ils
voient des voix convergée avant d'être
disponibles
et qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça mais
surtout se donner plein match chaque
milliards qu'on va mettre en quelque
part pour venir les quelques shows et
devra éliminer une autre projet
équivalent philippe couillard a fait sa
promesse il devra maintenant convaincre
qu'elles doivent être se réaliser et
surtout trouver les sous oui il ya
beaucoup beaucoup jean-sébastien de
défis prenons les presque un art d'abord
vous le disiez en début d'émission pour
ceux qui n'étaient pas avec nous
la mt donc l' agence métropolitaine de
transport qui chapeaute les
municipalités et tous les gens impliqués
10 nous finalement c'est pas le train de
l'ouest ce qu'on veut c'est pas un train
traditionnels ont vu un slr train léger
sur rail
moi c'est ce qu'on a appris aujourd'hui
en fait il ya un an et demi environ un
bureau des partenaires de l'ouest avait
été créé pour décider du projet optimale
qui qui aiderait à mieux desservir les
résidants de l'ouest les aéroports de
montréal certains élus de l'ouest et de
la couronne ouest participer l'invité
est effectivement on a décidé que le
plan au coeur de ce nouveau plan de
match dans l'ouest c'était la
construction d'un slr d'un système léger
sur rail qui partirait de pointe-claire
près du centre commercial fairview près
de l'autoroute 20 descendre et vers
l'aéroport de montréal deviendrait donc
là
la navette aéroportuaire tant attendu
s'en irait vers l'est pour rejoindre
éventuellement le futur slr du pont
champlain pour finir donc vers le centre
ville
on est aux aéroports de montréal
aéroport de dorval on a déjà sous
l'aéroport à une centaine de mètres des
comptoirs une des lieux prêts à
accueillir une future gare c'est un
projet qui coûterait de 2 à 3 milliards
de dollars c'est beaucoup d'argent c'est
plus que le milliard du train de l'ouest
patrice mais ce que nos sources nous ont
dit d'abord c'est que de construire de
nouvelles voies ferrées le long des
voies du canadien pacifique on ne
pourrait pas électrifiée ces voix là et
c'est pas vers cette solution non
environnementale que la mt que la mt
veut se diriger par ailleurs on affirme
que le coût d'exploitation annuel serait
beaucoup moins élevé une fois le projet
mis sur pied et finalement mais
actuellement la gare de dorval et à un
kilomètre de l'aéroport de dorval et ça
ce serait pas acceptable selon aéroports
de montréal dans un sale gamin km c'est
que vote dans le appelons le le vieux
projet du train de l'ouest vous
l'expliquais dans votre reportage le
train passerait mais passerait pas par
l'aéroport passera un kilomètre de là ce
qui voudrait dire une autre navette par
autobus dont ils joueront bien fou
finalement le slr vous l'expliquer c'est
plus cher mais la mt va faire la
recommandation passe qu'une fois que
c'est lancé ça coûte moins cher à
exploiter également cessé peu est
électrique et tout ça alors voyons au
sommet le problème c'est que c'est pas
le seul projet de la mt dans la région
va falloir trier tout seul faire des
choix là oui on revient sur le plan
20-20 2020 de lundi qui présentait huit
grands projets il y en a pour quelques
10,7 milliards de dollars de projets on
revient bien sûr sur le prolongement des
lignes de métro dans le métro de la
ligne bleue et c'est le plus avancé il
ya un bureau de projet qui a déjà écrit
et été créé pour 39 millions de dollars
donc ajouter six kilomètres de saint
michel jusqu'à anjou bon mais ligne
orange les jambes on verra
éventuellement par ailleurs le fameux
slr sur le pont champlain on en parle
tellement
on voudrait donc dans la kz2 le tour dix
de brossard jusqu'au centre-ville a
instauré la construire ce slr qui
desservirait peut-être 40000 personnes
entre eux il ya 48 le déplacement chaque
jour dans la voie réservée du pont
champlain montréal pourrait se rallier à
votre nouveau slr qui va dans l'ouest
qui s'est jouée dans un monde idéal on
veut l amt vous électrifie tout son
réseau actuellement il ya seulement le
train de deux montagnes qui est
électrifiée et une partie des tronçons
du futur train de l'est qui verra
bientôt le jour alors ça ça prendrait
des choux pour électrifier tout le
réseau finalement on veut également je
regarde mes notes service rapide par bus
srb spin off un autobus rapide pie-ix
c'est un projet qui date de 2010 sera
peut-être prennent neuf ans plus tard en
2019 un projet de 300 millions de
dollars une quinzaine de stations de
laval jusqu'à la rue notre dame ça aussi
c'est un gros projet et y en ad'autres
je pourrais vous dire qu'on veut
réaménager refaire le nouveau terminus
au centre-ville bon notre fameux train
de l'ouest
deux nouveaux sites d'entretien de
garage à la chine pointe saint charles
et réaménager le tunnel du mont royal
alors vu l'état des finances publiques
actuelles c'est évident qu'il va falloir
faire des choix
c'est très clair tout ça merci jean
sébastien on va donc suivre tous ces
dossiers là au cours des prochains mois
des prochaines années et on verra
qu'est-ce qui sera choisie mais dans
l'oise c'est vraiment fascinant de voir
y voir une bataille importante ce qu'on
dessert l'aéroport etc ce sms qu'on
investit le couillard ad-pa mal de
dossiers sur son bureau
merci jean sébastien roy